este lunes los niños de 6 a 11 años de
edad llegan de la mano de sus padres
para recibir la vacuna contra la comisi
9 en el ecuador la estrategia busca
inocular de manera progresiva a los
menores de edad previa autorización de
sus padres brigadas médicas asisten a
las escuelas para vacunar a los niños
primero recibirán las dosis de los 6 a
11 años con 11 meses y 29 días de edad
quienes recibirán la vacuna de sinovac
si bien los niños no se contagian tan
fácilmente como los adultos si se
complican se complican y la mortalidad
en estos niños que se contagian de kobe
de salta además de eso pueden
desarrollar un síndrome que se llama lon
kobe y no queremos que pase eso y
nuestro en nuestra población pediátrica
en un esquema de dos dosis y un
intervalo de 28 días recibirán su
inoculación los infantes de 5 años
deberán tener un cuadro de vacunación
completo para prevenir la disquería tos
ferina tétanos y poliomelitis y luego de
un mes de haber obtenido estas vacunas
podrán recibir hasta el commit 19 yo me
siento contento que mi hijo ya pueda
estar inmunizado para que pueda regresar
a las aulas porque sentimos que ya es
hora de perderle el miedo al virus
yo me siento contenta que hayan las
vacunas para los niños porque nos
permite que ya empecemos a socializar
porque los niños necesitan socializar
con los demás compañeritos y tienen más
oportunidades de seguir saliendo de la
lo que si lo permitirán deben entregar
una carta de autorización a la escuela
para vacunar a sus hijos el ecuador
buscará la inmunidad de rebaño antes del
mes de diciembre